terry you have a new memoir so did your
family help you at all with it yes they
did because they're in it like big time
okay yeah and again again my kids are
like oh my god you told her about this
she told about that uh but first of all
i love the fact i really like being
transparent because most men
don't talk we just don't talk to each
other and i said man we've got to i
wanted to make sure people didn't feel
alone you know especially the guys and
we talk about our own issues the things
we're going through and just opened up
these conversations and it's so
cathartic and it felt so good i think
everybody in the world needs to write
their own book so you can straighten out
your values know where you stand and it
was just so much fun by the way i'm not
just saying this i have started to read
it it is brilliant you've got to buy
this book and i really mean it i'm not
just saying this because i was told to i
love that you did it with your family
though because that's kind of true and
they'll keep you cause sometimes i feel
like your friends or your family almost
know you better than you do sometimes
even if you're like the most self-aware
person so that's really cool and also a
chance for them to be like uh no that's
not going in there
well my wife will tell me no that didn't
happen you need to straighten that right
that chapter out right yeah
here's what i said and here's how
amazing i was
[Laughter]
[Music]